hey guys today we're gonna talk about
the benefits of fennel seed hands-down
fennel seed is one of the best things
for digestion specifically cramping it's
really good also for a baby who is
colicky and the mother's still
breastfeeding the mothers should consume
fennel seeds that indirectly goes
through the breast milk and it will help
the baby so make note but it has
antispasmodic properties so it's going
to help spasm in the in the colon so
let's say for example you ate too much
and now you're all crampy you should
take some fennel seed right after you
eat that will help you also it reduces
gas it can improve indigestion okay then
we get nausea let's say you feel
nauseous after you eat you know this
this feeling like you're sick this can
help you simply because it increases the
flow of bile from the liver through the
gall bladder many people have a
condition where their liver and their
gall bladder has congestion and it's not
flowing properly fennel seed can help
increase the flow of that fluid it's
also good for coughing bronchitis even
asthma and one of the benefit it can
help a mother who's nursing increase her
breast milk but one other point which is
kind of a side effect fennel seed does
have a known side effect of increasing
contractions so if a female is pregnant
there could be an increased risk of
early contractions so you just want to
take that in consideration if you're not
ready to deliver your baby so realize
the benefits I'm talking about are from
the fennel seeds there's actually a
fennel vegetable that actually has a lot
of phytonutrients a lot of vitamins and
minerals and you cook that you will get
some great benefits not nearly as much
as the seeds and you can even consume it
completely raw and it's quite delicious
alright talk to you guys later so if you
want more knowledge on how to create a
healthy body subscribe now and get daily
notifications daily notifications that
sounds weird well I'll just remind you
on a daily basis about that